Now that you've learned a bit about what a
genome is made of, and how big the human
genome is, I want us to start thinking about
the human genome in context of other living organisms. I
want you to tell me, which species do you think has the biggest genome. Is it
Bufo bufo, the toad frog? Homo Sapiens, or modern humans, us?
Amoeba dubia, a single-celled organism, or is it gallus gallus, the
chicken? Remember that all living things have genetic material
that make up their own genomes, but not every animal's
genome is the exact same size. The human genome
has 3 billion base pairs and one copy. But how
do you think it compares to these other three
organisms up here? Now don't worry if you don't get
this right. Just take a guess, I just want
you to think about which other species, you think might
have more or less DNA in their genome compared to humans. So, go ahead
and pick what you think best answers
this question, which species has the biggest genome?